3gmt and the last star of former U.S
president Donald Trump has announced he
will run for president again in 2024
elections he launched his campaign at
his estate in Florida a week after
midterm elections Trump's earlier than
usual announcement is seen as a move to
discourage other contenders like Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
together we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable our country is in a
horrible State we're in grave trouble
this is not a task for a politician or a
conventional candidate this is a task
for a great movement
that embodies the courage confidence and
the spirit of the American people this
is a movement this is not for
any one individual
Renee O'Day is joining us no from
outside Donald Trump's estate in West
Palm Beach Florida
um I'm just looking at the monitors here
and Donald Trump is still speaking and
at the start of the speech he seem to
hit all the targets that he usually hits
what did you make of the of the speech
that's right Rob he definitely hit all
the targets that he usually hits and
then some like you said he is still
speaking now we're past the one hour
mark he was pretty right on time at nine
o'clock local time here when he took the
stage and and started to Dive Right into
things he said that America's comeback
starts right now and he was referring to
the four years he was in office he said
that everybody was thriving he mentioned
all different races uh he said that he
saved the economy during the covid-19
pandemic and he said inflation was
non-existent and drugs weren't making it
past the southern border so he spent a
lot of the time on the podium doing what
Trump does and that's tooting his own
horn talking about all of the decisions
that he made while he was in office and
why the decisions that are being made
now with the current president in office
aren't the correct ones it is an
announcement that we were largely
expecting and moments before he took
this stage actually his office filed the
paperwork necessary for his candidacy to
be made official so they did that he
took the stage he made his speech he
made his announcement on the backdrop of
it we've got a few dozen Trump
supporters that were camped out outside
of Mar-A-Lago outside of his Resort here
not as many as we normally would have
seen in the past but definitely just as
loud
so yeah we're just going to have to wait
and see what happens now over the course
of the next two years it's kind of a
sticky issue right now with some
disunity within the Republican party not
knowing quite yet if they're going to
back uh to back Donald Trump as the
candidate for the presidential election
in 2024 there is a push out there to get
Ron DeSantis the nomination for the
Republican Party he's the governor of
Florida he just won by a landslide in
last week's elections and some polls
that have been put out recently show
that if he were to go up against Donald
Trump that he's got about an 11
percentage point lead in some of the
main primary States some of the first
primary States so we're just gonna have
to wait and see which way the wind blows
with this with Donald Trump Anything
Goes
I know that he's been speaking to a room
full of uh very powerful and very
wealthy backers all of whom are Ardent
supporters of Donald Trump but I know
you've been talking as you mentioned
that our supporters outside Mar-A-Lago I
know you've been talking to them what
have they been telling you
yeah I'm not sure if you can hear the
horns and the cheering and whatnot uh
behind us but yeah I spoke to several of
them I spoke to a woman who was a
minister I spoke to the head of the
blacks for Trump organization we spoke
to a young man in his early 20s who is a
political commentator and all of them
tend to really say kind of the same
thing that they won't back anybody else
that Trump is their guy that they want
to see a return to constitutionalism and
that there is one person leading the
country for the people of the people
when asked if you know if he didn't get
the nomination from the Republican party
and it was Ron DeSantis who was the the
Forerunner for the Republicans would
they vote for him it was an Ardent no
some of the people said that he gets
paid to be the governor that's all he
needs to do he is not anything more than
a governor some people accuse some of
his uh mandates during covid for
instance and things like that as uh
hindering on on their rights so it's
it's kind of tricky they are very Ardent
Trump supporters they will not budge on
an idea of anybody else but Trump being
their president so it's going to be a
very tough road for whoever the
Republican nominee is if it's not Trump
in the future to gain that support base
to get those voters to vote for it for
them
Renee thank you very much indeed Rene
O'Day talking to us from outside Donald
Trump's estate West Palm Beach and
Florida
Trump's decision to run again for the
White House will raise questions about
the future direction of the Republican
party as Patrick o'hein reports from
Washington
he's back where he loves to be in the
spotlight and at the center of the
conversation former president Donald
Trump now says he wants to be back in
the white house but unlike the last time
he announced his bid he's now the focus
of numerous federal and state
investigations potentially hoping as a
presidential candidate he can't be
indicted analysts say it's not likely to
deter the U.S attorney general I don't
think so I think he might have to give
it a second second chance but it also
allows Donald Trump to really play the
victim and to say that he's being
politically persecuted by the Biden
Administration which is something he
likes to do anyways and he's coming off
a losing streak in the midterm elections
most of his hand-picked candidates got
the nomination to run as Republicans and
lost for the senate in Pennsylvania New
Hampshire Connecticut and Vermont and
Arizona were three of his top picks lost
his picks for Governors 10 lost and a
slew of house races saw his chosen
candidates lose Republicans were
expecting a red wave that would put them
for terribly in control of both chambers
of Congress historically it should have
happened but it didn't so now
Republicans are publicly and privately
asking themselves of the future of their
party is one not led by Donald Trump I
think our next candidate will be looking
to the Future not to the past and I
think our next candidate will win that
might be easier said than done while
Trump is being blamed by the Republican
media pulse show his base still backs
him still Republicans who have long
sought to distance their party from
Trump see hope what I do hope is that it
sends a signal to Republican leaders and
Republican primary voters that it is one
thing to win a Republican primary and it
is another to win a general election
what happened this November is a bunch
of Independence and college-educated
Suburban moderates rejected Donald
Trump's hand-picked candidates that said
he has won before despite the
controversies and countless crass
remarks the most infamous failing to
prevent his victory in 2016. and when
you started they let you do it you can
do anything whatever you want you better
run cops and even after he sent a mob to
the Capitol on January 6 for what turned
out to be a violent Insurrection
Republicans showed signs of abandoning
him only to come back days or weeks
later
this announcement now forcing Republican
politicians and financial backers to
wonder can they win elections with him
or without him it seems they will now
find that out Patty culhane Al Jazeera
Washington